let's move on to the problem that the
houston texans have with desean watson
it's easy to talk about watson wanting
out
it's not so easy talking about where he
goes next chris we had the tweet earlier
where
he surely is sending a message to the
texans and his supporters out there and
there are
many sports i feel bad for the texans at
this point
the average deshaun watson fan wants him
the hell out of there so
chris let's figure out where he may go
and i said yesterday
it's easy to figure out the teams that
shouldn't want him than to figure out
the teams that should want him
because there's a handful of teams that
shouldn't the bills the chiefs the
packers
for a couple of years yeah uh you know a
year or two from now they may feel
differently
the the probably
the seahawks right and the chargers
right
maybe maybe even i'll even say we said
you said the ravens right
you know maybe ravens the tennessee
titans i might i'm going to throw them
in there with the cur
i know we know desean watson's better
but i still think they got a really good
thing and they're not going to look to
upgrade or ruin that
little scenario there and did you say
the cleveland browns that's another one
i started to i'm not sure i know i'm not
sure i feel like they've made it now
baker's the guy he proved that to me at
least to where they shouldn't be looking
to
sell the farm just to make that trade
and and ruin something they're building
there
but what if you could send and look yeah
we're just going to spitball here yeah
right right we're not trying to we're
not trying to rain on the parade in
cleveland
but if you're a browns fan you got to
ask yourself this question if you're a
texans fan you got to ask yourself this
question
would you want baker mayfield do you
bring baker mayfield back to texas
there's an appeal to bringing baker
mayfield back to texas
there's an appeal to baker mayfield
playing houston texans
um and and if and if he if that's where
he would want
to be if he would embrace it right and
desean watson playing for the cleveland
browns
i i just you know that they could have
had him
that was the pick they traded the pick
to the texans right the deshaun watson
pick
they consciously chose more draft picks
over to sean watson
it's just it's something to think about
i think they are
in a very narrow
middle ground right where there's going
to be a lot of teams that
clearly should be there's going to be a
handful of teams it clearly shouldn't be
and i think the browns would kind of be
in that middle where it could go either
way yeah i hear that i think that's the
pack they're in i would hope they're
thinking hey
baker's our guy we've done a lot of good
things here let's not have to
trade away three first-round picks as
we're just on the cusp of
really completing our team and doing
that that's why i would not like to see
them do that at least at this point you
know they're close
we like what they're building there um
but i think the point of what we're
saying here and everything like that is
this is if it gets to this point and and
where it seems like it's going this way
it's going to be the most unbelievable
market and
and trade conversation ever around one
player we've never had a quarterback in
their
prime right now about to reach their
prime
maybe be available via trade that that's
where it's amazing
and yeah we mentioned the teams okay
that we know don't want them the teams
that have truly great quarterbacks and
they're going okay we're sold or
rookie great quarterbacks that are burro
herbert like you're talking about
now the other aspect of the conversation
i think we're in agreement here we
haven't really discussed this is
i don't think the crap teams of football
are going to be in this conversation
either one i don't think desean watson's
gonna go
like oh yeah i'll go to the jets or the
jacksonville jaguars right now
that's the first reason the second thing
is what what
why would those teams want to trade for
desean watson so they can be what the
houston texans and four and 12 with
desean watson
they have so many holes to fill to trade
for him i just go
well then you're the same crappy team
except you got a cooler quarterback
and you're not gonna be that much better
you might win one or two more games you
won't be two and fourteen
or you'll be four and twelve whoopty
freaking do
now the real story is all the other
teams we don't mention
and that's where hang on a second right
hang on a second tyler murray's another
team
they don't need them there right yeah
yeah you you mentioned
the jaguars i i have been fascinated by
the possibility of the jaguars offering
the trevor lawrence pick for deshaun
watson and what more
would have to flow in either direction
because that's what it is that could
happen right
trading we're trading the first overall
pick for deshawn watson you're trading
trevor lawrence for deshaun watson
because that's who houston would take
obviously i don't know that watts i
hadn't thought of it from the
perspective of
watson want to play for the jaguars but
he's got a lot more control over that
than trevor lawrence has over
because of the no trade clause he can
say i don't want to play for the jaguars
not that the texans would want to keep
him in the division
jaguars titans cults and obviously the
cults are a team that should culture a
team that would be in the front of the
line
right do you really want to do it do you
really want to trade a quarterback in
the division
philadelphia did it with donovan mcnabb
that was a trojan horse
the patriots did it with drew bledsoe
that was not quite a trojan horse but
they
they were ready to move on from bledsoe
and they got a first round pick so who
cares if he stays in the division
but uh yeah in the division is going to
be a tough sell i would not trade him to
the colts but
you know if the cults are one of the
handful of team that deshaun watson is
willing to play for
that's what that's those are the
participants at the auction at that
point
right colts dolphins and then who who
else do we
think because we know the dolphins we
keep hearing the dolphins
colts dolphins and who else would you
put on that list of the teams that
desean watson would say
yes i'll play well yeah to me it's
that's
going to be the thing that's what i
think so cool about this whole thing
i think it's going to be the teams that
are kind of good and feel like they're
in a good place as a total roster
that are going to look to trade for them
and go wait we're kind of good we got
pretty good depth i like where our
roster's at
the next two or three first round picks
aren't gonna make or break our football
team
we're missing the quarterback right now
so yeah you mentioned
two of them i mean um
we were talking about teams i mean the
saints what i mean the saints drew brees
retired
he's gonna go he'll he'll be like oh
sure i'll go play for sean payton
you know i would think that that's a
team that would jump out to him
i mean the pittsburgh steelers we don't
know what happens with big ben i'm just
throwing out all possible teams right
now that i think would make sense
you know the las vegas raiders john
gruden derek carr
i mean what that them new england
patriots
you know wait wait wait you can't trade
derek carr to the texans you can't
you can't do it you can't the team
that destroyed his brother david was no
blocking whatsoever that would be nice
because they didn't draft him i know
2014
right because because because their
mother is the same person
forget about assessing the quarterback
he's
david carr's brother so we can't draft
him that that was one of the reasons why
they didn't when he was a top prospect
yeah no i know you're right so that
might be a tough one that's out of the
loop there
but i think the the point is of what
we're making when you're talking about
this and the teams that
should at least think about it it's a
long list i mean minnesota
san francisco the carolina panthers
detroit
you know atlanta depending on what they
do with matt ryan
i just think there's a lot of teams
there that are very
you know good set up as far as
successful type rosters or have the
potential there and that's where i think
this could be really
unbelievable as far as the the trade
market and the conversation around
deshaun watson i think you could take
the falcons off the list simply be
sounds like their cap situation yeah
and they'd be taking a hit if they move
matt ryan and then on top of it
you have to bring in the desean watson
up
contra contract but but you know what
10.54 million
is his salary this year next year it's
35 million
which would speak to an extension at
that point
but for this year with the cap dropping
to 180 that's the number that i keep
hearing
10.5 million not a bad number
for deshaun watson and obviously the
texans would take a cap hit but if it's
it's in the low 20 millions to move him
if that's what they end up doing
uh we've seen the the steelers take a
cap hit in that
magnitude to move antonio brown and they
just got what a third round pick and a
fifth round pick back for him or
something like that so
i i yeah and again obviously we have to
get to the point where the texans are
willing to do it but i think we could
remove the falcons just because of the
cap realities
but it's really not a bad contract to
take on and some of the teams you
mentioned
really are intriguing to me and this i
want to start with the saints we talked
about this a little bit yesterday sean
payton could have drafted him yeah
sean payton was going to take patrick
mahomes if mahomes had made it past the
10 spot
they took marshawn lattimore with the
11th selection deshawn watson was
left on the board i i'm not sure that
sean payton's going to break the
draft pick bank to get deshaun watson
and that's the other side of this
you need to send him to a team that has
an established nucleus of great players
because
you're going to be giving up stuff
that's right get him right
and the more that you give up the harder
it's going to be for deshaun watson to
have a competitive team there's a sweet
spot there that could be
non-existent right where the texans get
fair value
but the new team hasn't mortgaged his
future to the point where it's not going
to matter to have deshaun watson
yeah that is the sweet the sweet spot
and i think that's why i i tend to think
it's
it's going to be the teams that are you
know more in the mix of the playoff
conversation or in the playoffs rather
than the teams that are in the gutter
and down there in the draft for the
trevor lawrence justin field sweepstakes
you know because of all those reasons
you just talked about you know
one yeah we don't want a team to get
ruined by the trade deshaun watson's not
going to sign off on oh
great you're trading me to a team that's
not good and now they're giving all
their trade their draft picks away so we
can continue to not be good i'm already
in that situation i would like to not be
in that
that's where yes that's where i look at
teams like the saints
you know the patriots and the miami
dolphins even though they're young
and yes there is some like there's a lot
of things that are set up there
they did a great job last year offensive
lines in a good spot
defensive lines in a damn good spot
maybe could use another pass rusher
li i mean linebacker secondary yeah they
need a receiver and all that but
i do think there's still one of those
teams in that conversation of course
have
you know a lot of draft picks to to play
around with and
and maybe even trade tua you know to to
uh to uh houston texans if they wanted
wanted him or wanted to make this trade
happen what do you think about the
broncos as a possible candidate
sean watson i mean they're one of the
teams we i threw out there because
drew lock certainly on the fence it
seems like he's going to be the starting
quarterback there
but i don't think they can be sold yet
like oh
he is the guy we talked about it last
week right denver is one of those places
where yeah you got drew locke
and i would have a really good you know
solid backup behind him
in case we see one of those dru lock
spurts that we saw this year where he's
just too loose with the ball and
throwing interceptions
vic fangirls want to go down the toilet
bowl with that so
uh i mean watson there
would he want it would he want it i
think he would patrick mahomes and
justin herbert
in that same division well i think when
he looks at those damn receivers on that
team
and then maybe looks at the way the
offensive line played this year he might
be go
okay i could deal with this i want out
of house denver's not perfect
but there's some things set up as far as
the defensive side of the ball
and the offensive side of the ball to
where there's potential for them to to
be a player
i think he would sign off on that what
do you think i
i think it would be a tough sell because
you're walking into a division that has
the potential to be very very
challenging
for years to come and yeah it would be
great to see desean watson and patrick
mahomes against each other twice per
year
but you're going to have to do a lot of
heavy lifting to get the broncos to the
point where they can compete and you're
giving up what two three first round
picks on the way in
to get to sean watson it's going to
hamper their ability to be competitive
there was a
uh and and i get odds from these
offshore gambling companies all the time
and i'll look at them and just delete
the email because
i'm i'm surprised they're still in
business because now that
gambling is legalized in more and more
american states they're clamping down on
the illegal offshore gambling but one of
the
one of the lists of odds that we
received back in august september time
frame
was the odds of uh who the patriots
quarterback would be week one of the
2021 season and the favorite was deshawn
watson
took a long way to get to my point what
do you think about deshaun watson
as the possibility of the next
quarterback
in new england the next franchise
quarterback for that team i
i think that he would be bill and josh
mcdaniels type of guy if josh is there
and not the eagles head coach
i do i think he's going to have some of
the you know the same characteristics
that they liked in cam newton and tom
brady and everything like that
you know plus i think he plays a style
of football
that fits their team he's a pocket
passer who only runs when he has to
and added to that played in billy
o'brien's offense and is going to have
some knowledge of the terminology and
going forward from there too
so i i would think that as long as bill
feels like he can pull it off and not
get ripped off with the trades and
things like that i would think the
player of deshaun watson
they would love him and especially the
way deshaun watson and he'd be
negotiating
with nick casario oh all right his
former lieutenant to get the deal done
if they tried to pull that off and and
see the thing is
the caserio knows exactly what bill
belichick thinks of desean watson right
how he would value him what he would
think he's worth and if there is any
possibility if there is interest there
and the texans decide to make that move
and watson would play for the patriots
that that would be an easy negotiation
assuming that there is a level of
interest by bill belichick
and assuming that belichick cracked the
vault open just a little bit for casario
to know what he thinks of deshaun watson
there's a damn good chance nobody other
than bill belichick knows what he thinks
of desean watson yeah
yes you're right there is probably a
good chance i would imagine though the
fact that they've had to play them over
the last few years that
those feelings have come out while
they're sitting in staff meetings and
bill's breaking down the houston texans
offense to where you know he brings up
the problems the quarterback
you know the challenges he brings to
their defense and everything like that
and then you start to realize oh bill
thinks a lot of this guy because he
we got some planning and all that so i
would think most of those guys there
know
how he feels about it desean watson but
you know i i really that that is
certainly one that i have thought about
i sit here and think about
the bears would they make that type of
play
you know i i mean that's another team
that's hey they had a chance back in
that draft as well to take him didn't do
that
you know that would be something else
you know i just i just think there's
going to be
a lot of teams very intrigued because
the guy is well liked
let alone the player is well liked and
you know he's got a lot of years left in
his career and i
just think that's going to be all
positives as far as people let me throw
a flag
out here that that uh i i it bears
repeating we brought it up with jalen
ramsey i know i brought it up with
jaylen ramsey
and and the extent to which deshaun
watson has become so disenchanted with
the texans that he wants
out do you have a fear if you're his
next team
that that's going to get turned on you
at some point i i don't think so
i think people will be able to look at
this for what it is and realize
if i was a quarterback of that team i'd
be pretty pissed off and have an issue
here too
and and we've had this discussion right
mike i mean all these coaches
they always start from ground zero when
they get a new player
they evaluate it for what it is and they
always think hey i can make it work and
i'll make this guy work in our building
and our culture and all that
i don't think he's got enough you know
bad
things or any bad things in his history
to make
an organization worried about that
aspect i i don't
all right let's try then to narrow the
list we've begun the process
i'm going to look at the grid that pete
has been maintaining while we've had the
conversation let's get a final list of
the teams
that we think should be at the table
could be at the table
and or would be at the table if this
trade happens
and if there is an auction for the
balance of the deshaun watson contract
dolphins no-brainer they're at the top
right do we put the patriots at the
table it sounds like a yes i think so
yes okay the jets no i don't think so i
don't think he's gonna sign off on that
and i would tell the jets why
i mean why so you can be four and 12
with desean watson i mean i
that that doesn't make sense to me i
would say no pittsburgh steelers yes
with the caveat that ben roethlisberger
would have to not return
right obviously you're not going to
trade for sean watson if he's coming
back he's got a 41 million dollar cap
number if he plays
for you roethlisberger that is in 2021.
colt's yes
even though we don't think the texans
would send him there
they're good fodder to drive up the
price elsewhere
jaguars are we yes or no on the jaguars
i'm leaning no
yeah i mean i want to lean no too cause
i just i have a
i guess i think i don't know if he'd buy
into that i know they have the number
one pick and trevor lawrence which will
be
you know appetizing to the texans but
yeah i think i'm with you there i want
to say no
because i just don't know if deshaun
watson would sign off on that right now
it's great watching pete's cursor fly
around on this he's doing good this year
thanks peter
we're we haven't thrown in many
curveballs yet though the las vegas
raiders yes or no well i think they're a
team that
listen derek carr is good you can really
win he's right on the edge of a top 10
quarterback in football
for for me at least but desean watson's
a top five quarterback in football i i
would think about it
and call and see what it takes i don't
think that's that crazy
chris i want to go ahead and plant a
flag on a concept here that may become
very real if this trade is going to
happen it may take a three-team trade
together it could be done
right because you're gonna have a team
that's got a quarterback that doesn't
need that quarterback but the texans say
no
i don't want that quarterback so instead
of three first-round picks
maybe it's two first-round picks
and uh the third one gets sent to or
wait two first-round picks your
quarterback gets sent to another team
pick to the texans right that said that
i could see that happening i don't think
that's a crazy thought there
the magnitude of this deal i mean again
we're expecting the richest trade hall
ever
right i think i mean at least in modern
history for what does sean watson
no mike lin's not the general manager of
any of the teams that would be trading
for deshawn watson so it's not going to
surpass the herschel walker debacle from
1989. no
i'm talking about modern history though
like you know we're going to see
bigger trade than jalen ramsey khalil
mack any of those guys who got
two first rounds right so uh but okay
all right so let's keep cracking away
here we hit vegas we hit denver we're
gonna say yes too
right so we're putting denver in the yes
the yeses are growing here all right and
that's just the afc
right all right let's look at the nfc
then we've got the east
washington would he want to play in
washington given where the team
currently is great off great defensive
line
right the weapons may not be where they
need to be you have to give up draft
picks to get him so that impairs your
ability to make the team better would he
want washington uh
i gotta say that's a close one there's
some positives there antonio gibson
terry mclaurin that offensive line
uh i'm gonna say yes for right now i
think it at least makes him think i
don't think it's one when they call he
just goes no way am i going there
at least he's going to think about it
giants with daniel jones and joe judge
and uh you know a team that was sub 500
but was still in the playoff mix until
the last week of the season
i the giants are a tough one just
because hey there is the gettleman
aspect of this whole thing you know
i mean i i think the giants would be
we'd certainly dabble in this i just
don't imagine the giants being in this
kind of conversation for a trade just
knowing and
living the giants life my whole life i
don't imagine that but i don't think
it's a thing he would say no to
i don't and i think they're a team
that's you know close
close to turning it around i don't think
they're that far off
too many hog mollies would be sacrificed
via draft picks i'm thinking dave
gettleman's going to want the lottery
tickets
and try to improve the team elsewhere
then go all in for a quarterback i think
he's going to be
gonna say no we'll put them there are no
all right uh the dallas cowboys they got
a weird
spot 37 million if they tag dak prescott
you get they they're they're they're all
in with dak they're no they're not going
back they're the eagles they got enough
of a mess
now he doesn't want to get jalen hurts
he doesn't want that it's it's
the nfc equivalent of the texans right
now different reasons but you don't want
to step into that right all right bears
are the bears a yes
i think so i i agree
right i mean again they're another team
that we've talked about they're closer
to the top than the bottom defense is
good
you know if they could re-sign it allen
robinson you got the mooney kid and
anthony miller and some tight ends i i
think that's a yes
all right how about the minnesota
vikings a three-way trade sending kirk
cousins to your buddy kyle shanahan
and uh that's the vikings picking up
deshaun watson
well that's funny and well i mean i i
mean jimmy garoppolo could go to houston
with nick casario i mean who knows what
the hell can i have that's i mean that's
something i was just gonna bring up i
mean but
okay yes let's say yes minnesota i don't
think he would say no to that
definitely at least he thinks about it
um detroit alliance that might be one he
might say no to right now
yeah i agree with you uh saints i i'm
i'm putting the saints in a no cause the
saints aren't going to want to give up
the draft pick capital to get him
it's going to be too expensive and they
have other needs that they need to
address although watson may want to play
there
how about the buccaneers i mean tom
brady's coming back next year right
yeah i think so i don't think they can
flirt with that yet yet i'm surprised
you say no to the saints so quickly
just like how do i
i think sean payton is confident he can
find the quarterback that he needs
without having to give up that much to
get him
that's the point mike you're exactly
right that's exactly right all right
carolina
i say yes on carolina right he may not i
don't know why you got christian
mccaffrey you got some
weapons rated receivers yeah yes right i
would think he'd look at that and go
wait i could come in there and be the
next superman and we can we might be
able to do something there i i i think
that would be a yes
we said no to the falcons because the
cap reality is disengaging from matt
ryan and then bringing into sean watson
the seattle seahawks we said no
cardinals we said no because of their
quarterbacks that brings us down to the
rams
and the 49ers rams rams can't do it
because of golf they don't have any
first round do they have any first round
picks left
yeah that's right yeah they they can't
mortgage their future
it's already been mortgaged and they've
screwed up their cap situation
with all these big contracts they've
given out that have blown up in their
faces
rams don't even entertain the thought it
can't happen what about your 49ers and
kyle shanahan a straight up garoppolo
for watson trade plus
more obviously coming from the 49ers to
the texas 49ers are one of those teams
that i would throw right on there and
then go
yes sir no doubt about it yeah i i mean
you know just again they're they're one
of the teams like we talked about at the
top of the segment where i just go
they're set up to win yeah they were
injured this year but the team is still
damn good they're kind of ready right
now
you know they're in their their window
for super bowl appearances and wins and
all of those type of things
to where yeah if i'm them uh or if i'm
deshawn watson i'm i'm definitely
thinking yes or thinking about that for
sure
does kyle shanahan want a guy who uh
he's not gonna be as as wedded to
running the offense the way that he
wants it to be run i mean
you know he had a chance to draft watson
or mahomes in 2017 but these don't
these guys don't fit the you know i'm
going to design the offense it's going
to work
we're not going to improvise we're going
to do it this way watson doesn't really
fit that i i
i think watson can fit that
though you know again we talked about
like he is a drop back quarterback he
wants to play within the pocket and dice
you up with his arm
he's not looking to just like get the
ball
let me look at the rush and run around
and just try to make backyard plays
i think you know again you're this is a
i don't know the answer to this i don't
know
because you're right kyle has a history
of wanting those kind of just like robot
quarterbacks i told you to do this and
do that
but i would also think kyle is being as
smart as he is and knowing that like
first off desean watson wants to do
what's right he wants to listen to his
coach and do everything you tell him to
do
and you know i would think within the
super bowl last year
and some of the quarterbacks he saw this
year that he might go you know what my
offense is good and i can coach the hell
out of things but
damn i'd like to have one of these guys
that can just bail me out of jail every
now and then when when things aren't
good
i would like to think that so i think it
could work
mike i really think kyle kyle could make
that work
texans and all general managers out
there we have done the work for you we
expect no compensation in exchange for
it we've narrowed the universe
to the dolphins patriots steelers
cults i thought we crossed off the
jaguars
jaguars are off the raiders the broncos
washington the bears the vikings
the panthers the 49ers i think so that's
the i think those are realistic
those are the possible destinations
right i think so and i think they're
realistically places that yeah desean
watson is not just going to say
no right away if he really does want out
of houston he'll think about it and
so i i like that list this was a good
good exercise i've been wondering about
this and i think this is going to be
something to watch here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports